this is where I'm at but now do pray for
Los Angeles it's very
bad wildfires have broken out and it's
now reaching to Hollywood and it looks
like a scene from hell it is very bad in
fact I was reading that some homes of
Hollywood actors have been burned down
by the wildfires I believe one of them
is James Wood the actor his home burned
down and several others the the
wildfires are out of control and it's
spreading to Hollywood it looks like a
scene from hell I'm not lying let me
show
you it looks like a scene from hell it's
bad
folks it is bad it's
spreading and people say it looks like a
scene an inferno from
hell it's out of control
and I know people who have oh Adam
Sandler right I know people who have
family and friends
there right here look Paris Hilton's
House burn
down Adam Sandler's House burn
down
right see it
bad they say it looks like an inferno
from hell it's very
bad and this is a
reminder your
wealth will do nothing to extend your
life right and your wealth is no
guarantee you'll be happy and prosperous
because all it takes is one Wildfire
consume your wealth your Mansions your
possessions look
does that not look like a scene from
hell does that not look like a scene
from Hell yep Ben Affleck's house
right and this is a
reminder right of what Jesus said this
is a reminder of what Jesus said look
what he said you
ready see you cannot prove the Bible
false you cannot falsify the Bible
because the Bible is truly God's word
and the god of the Bible is real he is
the creator he is
reality without him there would be no
existence what he says whether you like
it or not you're confirming every day
Humanity day in and day not they out
confirm the accuracy of the Bible
whether they know it or not whether they
want to or not and look what our lord
said about here reminder of the
beautiful words of our our Lord I'm
using the newly inspired version yep
Anthony Hopkins house bir down
too
right I don't have an opinion I didn't
watch it now watch here look what our
Lord reminds us of you want to hear the
words of the Lord and then we begin I'll
begin in prayer and we begin there's not
we can do
meaning we have to pray God have mercy
and pity on them because I saw one video
where a man and his dog are stuck in
their house and they're airing the fire
that's breaking around them and it
scared the hell out of me for the dog I
mean I feel bad for the man but the
dog
right I saw it and you see the fire let
me see if I can find that video let me
see man it was scary I felt not I don't
care for the man the dog you know I mean
let me sh see if I can find
it the
video scared me for the dog the fire is
right outside I'm like man what is this
guy doing because he doesn't know how to
escape he doesn't know how to escape
Where Are You Gonna Escape you're stuck
man let me find that video I was like my
goodness man and dog yep trapped in
housefire I think this is it here it is
right here watch
here watch here this is
it
look this is it New York Post oh boy
they'll probably Flagg me hold on man I
can't do New York Post they'll probably
Flagg Me I'm Scared hold on remember
YouTube copyright law allows for fair
use of excerpts for educational purposes
look at the fire here's the dog I don't
know man let which one should I do let
me do this
one gonna be okay you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be okay so yeah that's all
I can show
you that's all I can show you I don't
want to get flagged
all
right yeah it's bad guys you guys are
okay you're sitting there California
they're
fleeing a reminder of the words of Our
Lord reminder of the words of Our
Lord all right here you
go do not store Matthew 6:1 19-34 look
at the beautiful words of Our Lord do
not store up for yourselves treasure
Treasures on Earth where moths and
Vermin destroy and where thieves break
in and steel watch these Mansions homes
being burned to the ground and what did
Jesus say if these are your Treasures it
only took one fire to destroy your Tre
treasures and destroy your hope you see
how beautiful the teachings of Our Lord
are why we need to learn contentment and
I'm praying practice what I preach you
need to stop building up Treasures on
Earth so that the more money you
make the more money you make the bigger
Mansions you get the more cars you get
the more jewelry no the more money you
make the more you sacrifice to the Lord
the more you use it for the glory of the
Lord feed the hungry I'm not saying go
out and give money to people homeless
because many of them are homeless
because of drug addiction buy them food
or if you know a family that doesn't
have enough be there and give them money
monthly give them what they need to pay
the rent to get extra groceries do your
part help the widows go and give money
to the orphanages honestly this is what
Jesus demands of us may we practice what
we preach give money to the orphanages
send money to food banks send money
Jesus film project send money St
Jude by the grace of God may I
practice what I preach all
right don't store up for yourselves
Treasures on Earth where moths and
Vermin destroy and where thieves break
in and
steal but store up for yourselves
Treasures in Heaven where moths and
Vermin do not destroy and where thieves
do not break in and steal for where your
treasure is there your heart will be
also see how beautiful the teachings of
Our Lord are and you're telling me this
Bible is not
Supernatural
right wherever your treasure is that's
where your heart and devotion will
be so what does it do with treasures on
Earth if your eyes are fixated on More
Money More status higher position more
Fame
then you will be corrupted and polluted
because that
which you are consumed by becomes your
God right and that's why he says here
Matthew
6:24 no one can serve two
masters the Bible is a blessing and it's
healing Sonia if it's correctly
interpreted no one can serve two masters
either you'll hate the one and love the
other or you'll be devoted to the one
and despise the other and look what he
says you cannot serve both God and money
see either you love God and you slave
for God or you love money but you can't
love both because you won't be able to
love both equally and chances are your
love for money will become greater than
your love for God and you're going to
start compromising and prostituting
yourself and we see that don't we we see
that all around us how many Christian
singers do you know like Kate Perry I
don't know if you know it Kate Perry I
think that's her name started out as a
Christian singer but then the lust of
wanting to be more famous more popular
caused her to compromise and start
singing worldly songs
and and hence where is she
now where is she now where is
she what happened her love for money her
love for fame her love for status became
greater than her love for
God where is she
now you see you cannot falsify The Words
of Christ he's God and whether you like
it or not you're confirming his words
whether you like or not Katy Perry's one
right you see because why she thought
she could love God and money no you
can't you're going to love one more than
the other and you're going to subjugate
one to the other and most likely the
pattern of humans is God takes a back
seat to your money to your Fame and
Fortune we got it everyone getting this
right now what does he say then to
us why are you so fixing ated on having
more money having more possessions
having more Mansions having more cars
they're going
to deteriorate Decay corrupt and it
takes one fire to destroy all your homes
and your cars all your clothes and your
jewelry watch What's Happening Here look
at all these celebrities whose homes
burn
down don't be fixated don't let your
eyes G
on material
possession be fixated have your eyes
gazed on Heaven which is imperishable
and all the rewards and your mansion in
heaven which is
indestructible and that's why he says
therefore I tell you be
content therefore I tell you do not
worry do not worry
about your life what you will eat or
drink or about your body what you will
wear is not life the soul more than food
and the body more than clothes yeah
you're not a materialist naturalist
you're not someone who thinks it's only
this life and I die and I cease to be so
make the most of it you don't live that
way and you don't believe that you
believe there is everlasting life
there's a spirit realm God exists
physical death is not the end of you so
then why do you act as an atheist and
think this is the only life you have and
therefore you're going for the
Gusto is making sense therefore I tell
you do not worry about your life what
you will eat or drink or about your body
what you will wear is not life more than
a food and the body more than now he
gives you an example look at the bird of
there and don't you see that see the
illustrations of our lord they're
perfect and they're
beautiful don't you see pigeons they're
alive every day they don't work they
don't toil and God feeds them they
manage to find food because God
orchestrates and works in such a way
they get their food now look what he
says look at the birds of the air they
do not sow or reap or store away in
Barns and yet your heavenly father feeds
them are you not much more valuable than
they so here it tells you human
creatures are more valuable more loved
than other creatures he loves all his
creatures but he loves humans the
most everyone with me there we got
it now watch here can any of you by
worrying add a single hour to your life
now medically this is a
fact worrying doesn't add a single hour
to your life but it subtracts your
longevity even the medical field
confirms
stressing out shuts down your body your
immune system and stress can lead to
heart attacks even breaking down your
body resulting in
cancer so worrying won't increase the
longevity of your life but it will
definitely decrease it so why are you
worried why are you
worried practice trust and be content
because this two will
pass it will
pass stress is the number one killer in
men and what did our Lord say can any of
you by wearing add a single hour to your
life what's the answer
no are you Blown Away with the deep rich
beautiful wisdom of Our Lord that he has
the answers for everything and the
solution to your problems to my
problems but he's telling you you're
going to have to train yourself
discipline yourself
practice trusting
me practice and one thing if you want
proof that you'll make it the homeless
people are proof you'll still survive
they're still
surviving if you doubt what God is
saying that you will make it let the
homeless be the witness that in their
circumstance they've adopted and they
survive and they live
right they didn't die they're still
managing and they learn how to survive
in the most wicked of
weathers right if they can do it and
many of them don't even have God many of
them are in drugs what do you think God
will do for you in those
circumstances say I didn't know that God
is answering you isn't that the truth
the homeless are a lesson for you A Sign
from you what are you afraid of even if
you end up homeless you think I'll
abandon you and you're going to die look
at them look at the birds they still
survive they still
survive how many signs do I need to give
you that even in your most dire
situation I will strengthen and preserve
you if you don't Despair and panic and
just
trust
right is it sinking in